if it's not I'm gonna be yes
whoa oh no what I wanted to grab oh here
I thought I wanted to stop will thank
you mr. drill
[Music]
that's much better
all right coming out of the markup liars
demise I would forego traitorous
activities so we can all tossing around
the file boxes like a loser wandering
around aimlessly like a loser holding up
objects like a loser mix didn't actually
kill me but God you guys went for it
stop moving your hands it's very creepy
sorry stop it
wall buddy whoa hey you listen to me I'm
not a perform surgery on you I don't
care what you say in return I'm gonna do
it so let's get to it I'll keep a
lookout over here I'll make the Eagle
sound if I see anyone again what's the e
sound sound like like sim no that was a
test of the unmistakable
no I don't want to ready come on come on
I'm not doing it I'm not doing come on
cover him cold yada come on yeah bye-bye
owns it okay come on
two one in three two one nine and three
two one you're in this room I swear to
god you're in this room okay get in the
penis I won't have it it's very
uncomfortable in here wait what here we
go I just want this to be a nice normal
operation with
this has been markiplier highlights
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video and you'd like to see more than
please leave a like to let me know links
to all the videos are available in the
description below so check them out and
if you have a video that you want to see
in a highlights reel later let me know
in the comments below thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye